and I believe that free markets are the
best way to end global poverty not
government action markets on their own
pervasively persistently fail to move
people out of poverty or to achieve
economic efficiency state dominated
societies will often see an elite
capture the state and be able to oppress
the rest of the population through
states might state sanctioned coercion
the preconditions for development are
infrastructure education transfers of
Technology held all the areas in which
markets don't work well the problem with
our government is that they're
completely captured by the corporation's
the corporation's run the government and
then they ask you know what is the
solution to how do we solve this problem
well the government will solve it
we are truly honored to have a
conversation a special conversation
between two deeply informed people the
first is and I won't give you their long
resume their incredible credentials
speaks for itself it's all on a website
first we are honored to have any way you
can econ prof William easterly professor
easterly please come to the stage okay
all right well professor Stiglitz let's
hope you get a sack okay say the same
applause applause doesn't no contest
there okay and then we are equally
honored to have Columbia econ prof
Joseph Stiglitz professor Stiglitz
please come to the stage
I only want to mention a couple of
things that you a couple one thing you
don't know which isn't on the website is
that these guys are friends they've
known each other for years and they
don't agree about everything but they
definitely agree about their friendship
and then the only other thing they have
in common which is interest is that that
they're both Midwesterners bill bill was
born in West Virginia but raised in
Bowling Green Ohio and joe stiglitz
hails from Gary Indiana and you will
find you will find on professor
Ashley's website if you read carefully
the last sentence his big brag is that
is the 11th best known person from
Bowling Green I won't ask you who were
the other channel
professor Stiglitz you're up stage that
way you probably don't write that up but
there is a song called Gary Indiana from
the music man a great song which you
will not sing tonight and without
further ado I want the question of for
the conversation of the evening stated
again which is simply is the best way to
end global poverty free markets or
government action the format tonight
will not be Oxford cell voting it's not
a formal debate but it will be a
conversation but we're going to have ten
minutes of introductory remarks from
each and then we're going to have five
minutes of summary from each in between
we'll have dialogue between them and
then plenty of opportunity for QA and as
per agreement
professor easterly will go first with
the ten minute introduction professor
easily please take the podium
[Applause]
well I can't see anybody in the audience
it's dark can you hear me in the back
okay I am a soft-spoken guy from Bowling
Green Ohio so my job tonight I was
assigned to represent the case that I
indeed believed that free markets are
the best way to end global poverty not
government action
but first let's avoid the straw man that
anyone who advocates free markets
believes in some kind of zero role for
government of course I recognize there's
a role for governments such as providing
public services like police and courts
however the problem in development has
usually been too much emphasis on
government intervention and too little
on markets so in that sense I am arguing
markets are a much underappreciated way
in development of the best way to reduce
poverty I'm going to stress three
channels by which markets work well to
reduce poverty better incentives better
use of knowledge and then most novel is
better rights so let me start with
incentives the most obvious benefit of
markets are the incentives to produce
goods that create income and that meet
consumer needs state intervention and
markets destroys these incentives and
creates poverty let me start with
something that I didn't actually put in
my notes that it's kind of a favorite of
mine that like many of the things I'm
going to talk about these are examples
that I can back up with more systematic
evidence that we can discuss some of the
more boring parts of Q&A
I'm gonna give you man the examples my
first favorite example is a picture from
Cuba a Fidel Castro's funeral I don't
know if any of you saw this picture
Fidel Castro is being carried in state
pulled by an army jeep on a
magnificently bedecked flower bedecked
trailer with Fidel Castro's coffin and
they were soldiers of course marching in
a parade but the sergeant soldiers were
not marching in the parade they were
pushing the Jeep
I'm hoping for a better laugh live than
that apparently the incentives even for
Fidel Castro's funeral we're not quite
strong enough to make the Jeep work so
look that up on the internet more more
seriously I started my development
career as a very junior very junior
World Bank economist in 1985 visiting
Ghana and Ghana in 1985 was a pretty
grim place and partly because the
Ghanaian government had destroyed the
economy by severe interventions and and
price controls one example of price
controls is the price of cocoa prayed to
cocoa farmers when they sold cocoa was
so severely controlled they were only
getting 6% of the world price of cocoa
was going to the farmers that that is
the sixth the world price for the raw
material of cocoa they were getting only
6% of that price not surprisingly the
cocoa count economy of Ghana that used
to be a world's leading producer of
cocoa had collapsed and a lot of other
parts of the Ghanaian economy had
collapsed and so gone in Ghana in 1985
was extremely poor and dysfunctional
place it's been one of the pleasures of
mine throughout my career to watch Ghana
revive as those controls have been
lifted and prices and markets have been
liberalized in Gaudin Ghana's today a
much happier story with Wi-Fi and the
hotel rooms and a middle class and an
upper class and a lower working class
that is much less poor than it used to
be and that's been a arguably a result
of the great liberalisation of markets
that have happened since 1985 of course
that hasn't happened anyway everywhere
but it has happened in a lot of places
and has been documented to be
statistically associated with a revival
of growth in Africa and Latin America in
particular since the lost decades at the
80s and 90s in those regions one
exception to that positive trend is
today Venezuela as many of you know
Venezuela still has severe state
controls of
as suffering not only poverty but even
starvation for those living in Venezuela
there was a statistic that 74 percent of
the population in 2016 lost on average
19 pounds in 2016
due to the shortages of food created by
the state of interventions and food
price controls in Venezuela on at a
personal level I have a close friend
whose mother-in-law lives in Venezuela
and they they're desperate on how does
how to rescue her from starving because
not only is she not able to get food in
Venezuela the packages that they send to
her are confiscated by the government or
stolen so that's the kind of tragedy
that happens with state heavy state
intervention that doesn't let markets
work Towe believe poverty larry's next
go to the knowledge Channel
a great advantage of markets is they
place the decisions in the hands of
consumers and entrepreneurs who know
best what works for them give Joe extra
time to okay we don't we don't believe
in budget constraints we did where
economists so I completely forgot what I
was saying use okay knowledge channel of
markets place decisions in the hand of
consumers and entrepreneurs who know
best what works for them let me give you
an example of what happens when you
don't do that there was a UN appointed
Commission called the UN broadband
Commission that that was chaired by the
you were Wanda's dictator Paul Kagame
and Kagame himself set the tone for the
Commission he said broadband is so
wonderful he said the transformational
impact of broadband on people's lives
and global economies is no longer
questionable he was ordering us not to
question the benefits that the UN
top-down Commission had decided would be
achieved by imposition of broadband
everywhere there was one skeptic that I
read with some amusement that the UC
Berkeley researcher quintero Toyama read
some surveys that when a village gets
hooked up to the Internet on a broad
and peace broadband connection and this
is a quote from Toyama he said the
dominant uses by young men who are
playing games quote playing games
watching movies or consuming adult
content
so maybe broadband is not quite as great
as Paul Kagame he ordered us not to
question that was what actually works at
the bottom is often a surprise that is
best figured out by those at the bottom
by consumers not preneur it turns out
that consumers around the world wanted
cell phones a lot more than they want a
broadband cell phone subscribers have
rocketed in sub-saharan Africa for
example - do they now total 444 million
subscribers of cell phones reaching even
very poor people in in Africa who are
able to buy cell phone and very small
incremental minutes a kiosk in every
rural area and wrote Road by side and
this has had remarkable economic
benefits the firm m-pesa in Kenya
thought it was going to be a microcredit
organization but it found by accident
that the most the service that was most
in-demand was mobile phone transfers of
money from one mobile phone to another
which greatly enhanced and simplified
the lives of farmers and traders gave
them a lot of unforeseen benefits that
were only discovered by through markets
by those at the bottom an MPA now in
Kenya produces more transfers than
Western Union does worldwide six billion
transactions per year and Kenya done by
m-pesa so that's the kind of surprise
that the knowledge of consumers and
entrepreneurs of the at the bottom true
markets are able to figure out for
themselves now let me do the in the two
minutes remaining to me let me do no no
not that much let me do the I'm gonna
take a swig of water
okay the water the water doesn't count
right
so the the third and most novel channel
that I want to discuss is how markets
promote rights and so what do I mean by
that state dominated societies will
often see an elite capture this date and
be able to oppress the rest of the
population through state state
sanctioned coercion market systems are
inherently based on some degree of legal
equality of property and contract rights
among all the participants in market
including the poorest and the richest
and the reason that is is because market
transactions will not happen at all
unless a minimum level of contract and
property rights are recognized on both
sides otherwise one party would simply
cheat or steal or oppress the other and
there would be no markets they would
simply be cheating stealing and
oppression so for markets to exist at
all this kind these kind of rights have
to be accepted by all the participants
in markets now this is not an original
point there was someone a while ago who
saw this point named Adam Smith Adam
Smith commented in 1776 in the wealth of
nations on the discovery of America and
he said you know the discovery of the
Americas could have been such a great
opportunity for mutual benefits for
Europeans and indigenous Americans you
know Europe had commodities to offer the
Americas the Americas had new
commodities to offer Europe it could
have been a great opportunity for the
kind of free trade beloved by Adam Smith
but it was not to be and this is a quote
from Adam Smith the savage injustice of
the Europeans rendered an event which
ought to have been beneficial to all
ruinous and destructive to those
unfortunate countries so that's the kind
of realization that Smith had that the
the benefits of markets are only
available when there's a minimum level
of legal equality on both sides which
was obviously drastically violated in
in the Americas and the conquest of the
Americas of course this history is still
very relevant today I just got back from
a trip to Peru and which is very evident
from casual observation to an economist
or a non economist that the indigenous
Americans are still very much at the
bottom still suffering from the the
legacy of that oppression five centuries
ago that has continued to some extent
into the present with the capture of the
state Latin American States by the by
the elite class but on a more happy note
Smith offered a remarkable prophecy in
The Wealth of Nations about how all this
oppression would end and he makes it
clear that it would involve respecting
the rights of non Europeans he said mr.
quote from Adam Smith the inhabitants of
all different quarters of the world may
arrive at some respect for the rights of
one another
that's a beautiful phrase that I think
captures the essence of markets respect
for the rights of one another and I said
nothing seems more likely to establish
this equality than an extensive commerce
from all countries to all countries and
it's this somewhat happy news that in
our own generation this prophecy by Adam
Smith has some partially to some degree
come true that indeed Adam Smith was
right that markets are the main way
historically and in our generation of
globalized markets and migrants and
capital flows markets are the main way
historically and in our generation that
different races peoples and nations have
peacefully coexisted and cooperated for
their mutual benefit and that is to me
the final and most beautiful benefit of
markets thank you very much
yeah thank you
frustration Lee and Fester Stiglitz has
decided to let you from a seat and and
professor this you have as much as 12
minutes to go he took 12 minutes so take
it away so first begin by the question
just remind you is the best way to end
global poverty free markets or
government action
so first you should understand we're
never going to end poverty the Bible
says the poor you should always have
with you so so it's over reaching but if
you look at it historically the single
largest episode of the reduction of
poverty in history mankind in a short
span of time was in China over the last
35 years where 740 million people have
moved out of poverty as a result of
government government actions now and
this links with what bill said it was
government using markets so it was the
move of of a Chinese government to
recognize that markets are an important
instrument and that's really highlights
the what I wouldn't want to say is
essential message
you always are going to have a mixture
of governments and markets and the only
success is going to be where you get the
right mixture I'm I'll try to explain
why I think you need probably a greater
mixture of government than bill does
that a lot of the failures are where
that balance got wrong on the side of
having too little government that
markets on their own pervasively
persistently fail to
move people out of poverty or to achieve
economic efficiency but there are many
instances of government failures as well
and so our objective has to be to try to
construct efficient government's not
something we have in the United States
you know or our governments that expect
reflect rights something that we are
having a problem with right now but also
we have to have markets that work well
so if we look at what region of the
world there has been the most success in
development and development in
particular that moves people out of
poverty extensions China it's really
East Asia and in all the East Asian
countries there was a large dose of
government they all used markets and in
fact there's a whole literature talking
about the way they you they they you
might say that they they restructure the
markets they govern the markets and they
made the markets work for their society
so they viewed markets not as an end in
themselves and themselves but as an
instrument and an instrument which
helped move them in the economic growth
from very poor countries into moderately
successful countries in some cases quite
successful Japan being one of the more
successful Korea when it began its
development at average education level
point four point three years it's income
per capita was around one hundred and
fifty dollars and today it's one of the
members of the organization of Economic
Cooperation Development one of the
advanced countries and we during samsung
telephones and in lakhs of products and
chips annex it was government
development on the other hand the model
that the World Bank used some of you may
know I was the chief economist of the
World Bank and I had the unenviable task
of trying to reform them and the one of
the later chief economist went on to say
that my main success at the World Bank
was actually changing the IMF so which
was across the street but the point is
that at the time I came to the World
Bank the dominant ideology was called
the Washington Consensus which was based
on a strong dose of that belief that
markets worked well and it permeated all
all of their policies and it was in some
ways driven by the belief that you
needed to rebalance that in the
direction that bill said to get more
markets and less government and the fact
is that the countries that relied on the
Washington Consensus were by and large
unsuccessful and much less successful
than the East Asian countries where they
had a bigger dose of government in fact
overall the Washington Consensus
policies which were called structural
adjustment in the context of Africa
actually led to the deindustrialization
of Africa and actually impede Millette
to a quarter century of stagnation so
there's going to be always a debate was
the failure of Africa a result of too
much government through marketing Borges
in agriculture and that did play a role
or was it in fact the result of the IMF
coming in and insisting on the
government on government not doing
things leading to deindustrialization
Inlet and a quarter of lost quarter
century and I I'm much more of though at
a review some argue that going forward
the mix in Africa should be tilted to
mark X because of the large governance
problems in in Africa but if you go back
to the period at the beginning of the
East Asia miracle the 1970s 60 70s 80s
what you see is that the governance in
East Asia was far from perfect and in
fact what happened in the Washington
Consensus countries was it undermine the
efforts to have a well-functioning state
so it by eviscerating the state you it
wasn't allowed to develop the
institutions that make you know the
systems of checks and balances the kinds
of institutions that make an effective
democracy work so by by limiting the
state
it actually eviscerated and and
therefore weakened development but even
in Africa among the most successful
countries happened those where the state
has taken a large role the development
state and I don't want to claim that
there are Paragons of democratic values
but they have succeeded in reducing
poverty I don't know how many remember
the pictures that you used to see on TV
of young children starving in Ethiopia
you don't see those pictures anymore and
why was that you know what is it a
miracle the markets no what happened was
the government built infrastructure and
so it used to be that you'd have a
famine and one
in the country and you couldn't get the
food over to the next and that
construction of infrastructure made a
big difference but it was also the
develop you know the the Ethiopia over
the last about more than decade now
10-15 years has been growing at 12% a
year actually faster than China's growth
in its average growth rate it was 10% a
year over the 35 year period that was
because the Ethiopian government took a
very active role in promoting
development it was they were trying to
learn the lessons that have made East
Asia successful and applied them to
Africa Botswana has had one of the
longest periods of successful
development of small country but there
are no BIA has been very successful and
these are all countries and successful
in reducing poverty and they because
they've had a strong role for government
someone that may have a greater
commitment to democracy and than others
Namibia has actually a stronger
commitment to press freedom than our
president seems to have a commitment
towards and you know it says you know
whenever a contractor comes in he
invites the president and wants to
discuss something he invites the press
in and he says that discourages bad
behavior so he understands the president
you know the role of transparency well
the reason development state has been so
successful is the preconditions for
development are infrastructure education
transfers of Technology health all the
areas in which markets don't work well
and you know this is about development
but I can mention even in advanced
countries basic research the development
the Internet rely on government the
discovery of DNA
we left at the market who knows when we
would have had these advances so all
these are things where for good reason
economists have explained why markets
don't work well one has to understand
that there are domains in which markets
work but there are others in which they
don't work well and even in vast
countries unfettered markets don't work
well I think we learned in 2008 the need
for regulation in the financial sector
we there's a role for government in in
promoting investments in infrastructure
and in in R&D and so even those are
necessities in developed countries it's
even more in developing countries and in
terms of of the broad framework of of
rikes you know one person's freedom and
is another person's unfreedom you know
the right to have a gun to shoot
somebody means that another person
freedom to live is being impaired so
that you can't look at these without
looking at the balance of of those and
so the the bottom line is well there are
many examples of government failures
there are also many examples of market
failures and you need the balance of the
two to get a society to function well
thank you
[Applause]
we've allotted twenty minutes of
dialogue and conversation between you
two before we go to Q&A I see that
Professor recently has written a lot of
notes and so maybe maybe were to get you
asked you to lead the discussion I can
ask a couple of questions get it going
but I think you have a lot of
provocative statements down there so why
don't you start I wasn't I swear I just
saw you I just heard the scribbling byte
loud scribbling let's talk about
Ethiopia so let's think in terms of
these these channels of incentives
knowledge and rights so the problem with
sort of government experts and eight
experts also which are sort of in the
same category is that first of all they
don't really have very strong incentives
to get things right because they don't
really get rewarded for getting things
right or get punished for getting things
wrong because I can tell you from
personal experience as a World Bank
economist I often got things wrong and
got promoted for it so so the incentives
are not very good the knowledge is not
very good and the rights the respective
rights is not very good so let's use
Ethiopia as an example I grew oh you
have a very good point about the
infrastructure being a good thing for
reducing poverty in Ethiopia reducing
famine but the big picture is the the
famines in Ethiopia were happening
during a extremely authoritarian regime
called the derg of a ruler who took the
Soviet economy as a model how to run an
economy and that's when the famines
happened during that Soviet period of
Ethiopian policy and the big revival of
economic growth that Joe was talking
about happened precisely when the new
ruler came in and overthrew the Derg and
and brought in a much more market
approach to it was this to be a
conversation or do you want to give you
a chance to respond I just tried to pick
up a word revival that's not exactly the
right word because prior to the Derg was
Haile Selassie and okay to set to two
millennia of stagnation so yeah well I
was I don't have all the data from two
millennia so concentrating on just
concentrating on the period one minute
Hammond's that you referred to the
famous famines in 85 and they were there
before that - yes there were famines
under Haile Selassie - yeah yeah so
there's more going on than just the only
thing being the I concede that point
thank you Joe
but so the only problem with the new
regime in Ethiopia is it still wasn't
infatuated with with many state
solutions that did not work out that
well so let me give you another example
of knowledge kind of misfiring they
thought a great idea would be to a
program called village ization that was
started in 2012 and that involved the
the forced resettlement so they also
failure to respect rights and
unfortunately the aid experts also
endorsed this approach and showed a
shocking disregard for the property
rights of ethiopia ethiopian farmers who
were being forcibly resettled in the
government model villages that the
government thought would be better for
them except the model villages didn't
have like water for their cattle didn't
have fields that were fertile they were
much worse than the villages that they
were forcibly resettled from that they
had freely chosen and a lot of the
victims of this policy in the province
of Granville I wound up fleeing into
refugee camps into Kenya and one of them
made his way to Britain and sue the
British ad agency for supporting all
this stupid stuff so you know there's a
good example of how incentives are wrong
knowledge is flawed as faulty and as a
shock irrespective
the rights of poor people involved in a
lot of these state sort of an eight
expert kind of course or sessions any
professors a chance to respond to they
said you know there's going to be
mistakes in any system you know no no
government ever was a result of so much
economic damage as the collapse of our
financial system which cost us five
trillion dollars and your five billion
dollars so so I don't want to say
there's any monopoly on inefficiency and
and failure but if you look in the case
of Ethiopia and I've spent a lot of time
there the fact is that they did correct
these mistakes and that's why over a
long period of time they had an average
of twelve percent growth rates you know
they they do make mistakes absolutely
and and sometimes it takes them longer
than extra and during this particular
period there were violations of Rights
and that that's also clear but they had
a understanding that you're not going to
have an accumulation of knowledge unless
you have education systems and people
were so poor that they couldn't have
private education and when you have
private education you wind up with Trump
University so you you and remember it
America's private schools we call
private universities are all
not-for-profit they're not based on the
profit model the only private ones are
the the exploitive private ones that
don't deliver an education for anybody
do you want to make a remark about
anything LP but I just one more thing
about a Theo Pia and I think you know
all these you know development is really
difficult it did succeed over this long
period of time of really doubling you
remember if you grow at 12% a year for
10-12 years you multiply incomes by
fourfold
that's a big deal when you have a very
poor country you move a lot of people
out of poverty if you go to artists you
see what what has been done and again
it's too soon to tell but the big
success of getting a new government that
has released people out of prisons that
has really moved very big Democratic
strikes is evidence that over time these
things not only show up in terms of
reducing poverty but I also even art
having troops in terms of a movement
towards I don't want ya but towards
democracy and human rights well I agree
with you Joe the the mechanism for
correcting mistakes in Ethiopia was a
massive popular protest that got rid of
the old government doing all these
stupid things and brought in and the new
government you're talking about that as
promising liberalisation and enhance
freedom for the open citizens did you
want to comment also quickly on this
point that writes that my freedom could
be someone else's unfreedom I don't
think that's a I think the correct
understanding of freedom is that we can
all reach a mutually consistent
understanding of our own zone of
personal freedoms that we're all willing
to respect for each other and so that
that a proper understanding of freedom
that we see most most exemplified in
market transactions is that freedom is
not a zero-sum game it's not a zero-sum
game or more freedom for me means less
freedom for you more freedom for all of
us means that we can all engage in
mutually beneficial transactions through
social interactions through markets
through all based on the understanding
that we that we all have our own zone of
personal personal respect for our rights
and personal liberty and property rights
and contract rights and human rights all
those zones of freedom those are a big
positive sum game these are not
something that we achieve at the expense
of each other these are something that
we all achieve together for mutually
beneficial transactions
markets yeah when they're well-regulated
that the point is we don't have adequate
regulation you have a financial sector
that can impose costs on the rest of us
our economy goes down we suffer five
trillion dollars and that's why we get
together in collective action and say
that system didn't work very well we
need to have a different set of
regulations and then you have to also
understand that there there are large
asymmetries of information there are
people that can exploit other people
there are there is market power you know
Adam Smith was talking about a
competitive economy that's what he real
said is what delivers efficiency but
memory another quote of Adam Smith is
that you know a businessman seldom get
together without conspiring against the
public good and what he was talking
about was market power and the antitrust
laws were designed to address that but
you need regulations because otherwise
you wind up with market power and when
you have market power you don't get the
benefits of a market economy so I mean I
could go down lots of other Elissa a
very nice book by George Akerlof and Rob
Shiller called phishing for fools and
they use the word P P H from the from
the internet and the point is that firms
make as much profits it's easy to make
profits by looking around the world for
fools that you can exploit rather than
making a better innovation and if the
government says you can't do that you
can't engage in abuse of credit card
practices you can't make unsafe products
that the dangers of which only get
explore this
too late those kind of regulations then
encourage people to actually direct
their energy of innovating for things
that actually increase societal value so
Joe I get your point I mean it's
certainly true that in markets you can
have things like insight information
could lead to deception and cheating of
one party by another that would violate
the yeah the whole idea of mutually
beneficial transactions but it seems
like you're imagining a kind of
idealized government that can fly in and
rescue this situation the problem is
government regulators also have I mean
if you want to talk about fools I would
talk about the people who are in power
in Washington at the moment no that's
look at the as I say a gray nomination
for the biggest collection of fools that
I know of anyway once you know once you
give power to once you give power to
governments to regulate if you give them
a lot of power to regulate then you know
that power is gonna be inherited by a
group of fools like what we have two or
chanita at the moment so so but there is
no idealized government Savior it's
gonna fly in who's got again do they
have the right incentives to get it
right do they have the knowledge
together right do they really respect
the rights that were being violated by
cheating that's the questions we have to
be asked so so anybody who's living
through the United States right now
knows about government failure so and
and excellent across the political
spectrum so so that's that seems we can
agree on on that the the question though
is all you know shakez percent to err is
human all human institutions are
fallible and the question is how do you
create a system that works the best and
that involves within our government
checks and balances and within our
society checks and balances and those
checks and balances have the market
checking government and the government
checking markets in civil society
involved in checking both so if I asked
would I rather have imperfect
environmental regulation or
what we had before we had environmental
regulations where people were dying in
Los Angeles from pollution I would
rather have imperfect regulation I don't
think I want the world to fry from
climate change which is what we would
have if we don't have any government
regulation so it seems to me that you
know we have no choice but to say at
least in some areas you need regulation
let me go back to another example back
in the beginning of the 1920s let me
just clarify again that's a strong man
to say that anyone advocating markets
believes in zero government intervention
to correct something like an
environmental pollution problem so
obviously we agree on that yeah let me
talk about food regulation you know the
reason we began having why are we
talking about the u.s. so much I thought
we were principal global poverty
developing countries the reason we have
food regulation is because the Upton
Sinclair wrote a very forceful book
called the jungle in which he showed
what happens you know the what the meat
packers were like and people didn't want
to eat meat and they came to the
government and said give us some
assurance that we're not going to die
when when we eat beef and and it worked
for a while but now we don't shouldn't
eat beef because of what it does to the
environment but that's another batter
but in developing countries what I was
saying is you know East Asia did not
have perfect institutions but yet they
were able to do better than historically
any purple countries had ever done in
terms of economic growth in terms of
development and in terms of moving
people out of poverty they're not
perfect institutions they have there
were they had instances of corruption
they corrected them and so it what I
guess I'm arguing you need these checks
and balances and you need
an important role for government man I
try to join the issue and ask I seem to
like the divide between you two is that
Billie Ashley is saying that in crucial
respects government is far more fallible
than markets in in in developing it with
respect to issues of development and so
you not built so maybe you want to
defend that point in it let Jo respond
boys why is government more fallible
than markets elaborate for a moment
again remember the especially if you're
giving the government a lot of power to
determine the development strategy then
the problem with that is the the elites
in any society can take advantage of
that power can capture the state and
then use that power to oppress the rest
of the rest of the society so we have to
talk about politics again which is the
you know the problem with the idealized
government to the rescue of the model
and what is what is the advantage as
well joke about this the you know
someone says the you know the problem
with our government is that they're
completely captured by the corporations
the corporations run the government and
then they ask you know what is the
solution to how do we solve this problem
well the government will solve it you
know the corporate dominated government
that is alleged to exist it's not gonna
solve the problem of government being
dominant but one of the checks and
balances and markets they were elaborate
well again the markets inherently have
you know I I personally refuse to eat
poisonous meats that helps kind of keep
the meat producers in check my whole
family refuses to you by poisonous meat
in the market so that that's a kind of
natural market force that tends to be a
check on meat producers not the poison
poison all of us so there's some
built-in incentives and markets that you
can only prosper in markets if you
satisfy the consumer so the consumer has
power over the producers that's the
other great invisible hand celebrated by
Adam Smith the invisible hand of
consumers searching for the best
possible deal the best possible price
for the best possible quality
and and that and also brings in lots of
knowledge you know consumers have an
incentive the firm's have an incentive
to know what really is in the meat and
so you know there will be a search for
you know what what are really the
ingredients in the meat and there'll be
even firms will it come to exist that
tests the meat and that advertise what
and so there are some natural market
solutions to these problems that are
have better built-in incentives than the
government does governments which can be
captured by elites and and not act in
the interests of the citizens very well
so first let me say talk about Adam
Smith if you read the body of Adam Smith
he had a much like read to do actually
recently read both the whole theory and
all settlements including a whole lot
more of genomics and and the point is he
has a much more nuanced view if you read
the whole and I'm not graphic but I read
enough of it to know he he he was aware
of the monopoly power he was aware of
the importance of government in
education the importance of government
in lakhs of other areas you you know you
quoted the the and he he was writing in
particular before the modern innovation
age now why do I say that's important
because information and knowledge is
what week sink of has quit essentially a
public good that if each of us had to do
research about whether every producer of
beef was safe or not we couldn't operate
and yes you could have private agencies
do the inspection but then we start
worrying about the incentives of those
private agencies an example of that is
the credit rating agencies they were
doing quote evaluation but they were
being paid by the banks and their
incentives were perverse and that that
monitoring function doesn't work very
well in the private
except in a few instances and that's why
people have turned to government to look
for me for financial sector regulation
so and in a modern economy where
knowledge is so important with the
production of the knowledge itself if
value to everybody in society you're
going to have to have a significant
government to do research about DNA to
do a lot of the basic innovations that
are necessary for a knowledge economy to
function like the Internet as an example
before we go to Q&A
I just wanted to the moment for you both
to address the issue of China Joe
brought it up the biggest success story
China my question to you Joe is do you
think right now that the mix between
government power and market power is
about right in China they're bad have it
right or is it is it no do they need
more market or more government in China
oh I think they need more market market
okay yeah say okay and then I guess you
could rebut do you maybe want to comment
on that yeah I mean China is a good way
to again I keep having the feeling Joe
that you keep going back to this
idealized government that is kind of
notes that idealized like you said as a
matter of fact that the government
didn't move seven hundred forty million
people out of poverty that was the
question we were asked what was
successful and no private market has
ever done anything like that oh yeah
when the government let a market economy
emerge after lots of protests by fire
farmers on collective farms there was a
big transition from a planned economy to
a market economy that's that's the
market economy yeah all right let me sit
just make one final point about
challenging their sort of idealized
government to the rescue thing is even
more of a problem in very poor countries
that have very adverse conditions due to
history and the legacy of previous bad
colonial institutions they have a clean
you know what knowledgeable government
fixing all of these problems the idea
that as state agency would kind
get it right and be honest is under
great threat in a poor economy with with
poor institutions where there's serious
problems of corruption elite capture all
the things we've been talking about that
take us very far away from government
being a good solution to these you know
kind of panacea for these problems that
we're talking about okay thank you okay
we have 30 minutes for Q&A please line
up please try to phrase your question as
the question and and then tell us of
course if your question is that either
of the two parties that's fine if your
question is directed to professor's
tickets or possessor usually say so
first question here please yeah go ahead
please ask a question yeah yeah okay
yeah my question is for professor
Stiglitz about Venezuela in 2006 you
wrote that then President Hugo Chavez
was unfairly castigated for being
populist and I'm quoting aimed to bring
education and health benefits to the
poor and to strive for economic policies
that not only bring higher growth but
also ensure that the fruits of the
growth are more widely shared when you
were in Venezuela the following year at
a time when President Chavez was being
criticized by the World Bank and had
already been cited by Human Rights Watch
for abuses according to news reports you
met with shabbos and were quoted making
positive comments about him based on the
PowerPoint presentation still available
for download on your website you also
gave a speech sponsored by the Bank of
Venezuela where you criticize so-called
market fundamentalism and cited your own
research showing how Adam Smith was
wrong eleven years later Chavez's
policies have led millions to flee the
country and as Professor easterly
mentioned there are people starving to
death in what was once among the richest
countries in Latin America my question
is as follows has Venezuela's economic
collapse led you to reconsider your
views on the role of government and
managing trade currency exchange rates
and keeping inflation in check and are
you concerned that your endorsements
back in 2006 and 2007 bolstered the
credibility of the Venezuelan government
so first I did not endorse here for not
reading my old quotes
what no if you if you notice what I said
I did not endorse what I said is that
here's the focus on education and health
was commendable the fact is that when
you know Venezuela
was the richest country in Latin America
and yet in all this period while it was
before before sheva says it was a
richest country two-thirds of the
country was in poverty and it was that
which gave rise to the feeling among
large numbers of the people that
something ought to be done and Chavez
offered for the first time something
some the hope which he did not deliver
on that something would be done about
education and health for the vast
majority the previous government's had
not done that they focused on taking the
wealth of the country and giving it to
the Leakes the small group in the top
who did were doing very well now
obviously it's been an utter disaster of
what what has happened I don't you know
nobody can defend Maduro and what has
happened and the loss of of rikes
nor can anybody to defend the the
undermining of the democratic
institutions that even happen during the
latter years of Chef as I think what I
was emphasizing was just the fact that
in this period prior to shop as all this
wealth of the country was being used for
the benefit of very few people at the
top and it just was a scandal that
two-thirds of the population were in
poverty well in all fairness I think the
quote also is that you wrote in your
book that Chavez had a commitment to
higher growth and he wanted to do it he
didn't deliver he was really doing ok no
that's but
at the time the economic freedom index
was slashing the World Bank was saying
that his policies are destructive
they're already saying that at the time
that you were endorsing I didn't forgive
me a veteran I was not endorsing his
natural policies I was very clear it was
just the focus on education and and hell
but I would commit an entire growth he
wanted to get higher growth in the end
it turned out they didn't know how to do
it okay and yeah and got negative growth
as we economists say but I okay well I
guess you answered the question bill do
you have any comment on the question
about Venezuela and and jobs in to us
Oh Joseph forgive me Joe's a role I
haven't read any of your old quotes as
well so I have nothing to say I mean I
think this is an example of this
discussion we're having about the
Washington Consensus I mean I think the
Washington Consensus what it got wrong
was there was a big attempt to sort of
coerce other countries into adopting the
advice of IMF and World Bank experts
which is the worst possible way to say
any sell any program of reform and it
led to this kind of backlash that
resulted in Chavez and resulted in Evo
Morales and Bolivia and Daniel Ortega
coming back in Nicaragua and and things
like that but else elsewhere there were
sort of homegrown efforts towards
economic reform that we're moving away
from the kind of things bad things that
are happening in Venezuela now then this
was extremely high rates of inflation
extremely high black market premium of
exchange rates of the black market
exchange rate much higher than the
official exchange rate is fairly
destroyed international trade so
measures of these things elsewhere in
the world have resulted in the first of
all when those things are bad there's
always almost always very negative
growth and when those things are
corrected as they were in the aftermath
of the Washington Consensus like in
large parts of Africa and Latin America
there actually was very strong positive
growth response to those reforms that
corrected those extreme distortions of
markets and so I think Venezuela is an
exact honor factual that reminds us of
what would have happened in
world without this movement towards
market reform that Marko reform is
actually much more of a success than
where it hasn't happened that there's
been great failure okay I guess the
structural adjustment programs in Africa
led to a quarter century of stagnation
so the that I viewed was was a big
failure you know 25 years of of no
growth and yeah can we be precise about
this so there was bad growth in the 80s
through the mid 90s during that period
inflation was extremely high black
market premiums were still extremely
high interest rate real interest rates
were negative too destroying financial
markets and then after the mid-90s in
most African countries those things were
finally corrected and then growth did
revive after the mid 90s in Africa up to
the present and there have been now 20
years of very positive growth in the
aftermath of correcting those
distortions so the kind of stagnation
you're talking about was when that
market distortions were still extremely
severe and when they were finally
corrected then growth did revive I'm not
well this is a technical discussion
because I I think actually the growth
revives the most important part of the
growth revival was actually as a result
of China's ascendance demand for natural
resources going up and the price of
natural resources going up that was a
real boost to African acts if you look
at where what made the difference for
most of the African countries that's
where it really showed up so so there's
a the context you think that that Africa
the the government oppression of the
economy lifted and growth happened and
Jose and then the rest and what I'm
saying is if you look at the data it
de-industrialized as a result of the you
know that that and even in in like 2014
the fraction of GDP
output an employment that was in say
manufacturing industrial in Africa was
lower than in the 1970s so it was a you
know a long period where rather than
leading to the next stage of development
they were really frozen and so you know
they did so that they really didn't get
on to a viable growth path that would
have led to to reduction of poverty
except in places you know where there
were lakhs of natural resources and in
places like Ethiopia Namibia you know
where they really had a more active
government policies to promote growth
yes
question of the Manhattan don't have to
identify yourself just ask the question
you know we don't know we don't care who
you why I ask the question okay well one
of the things I do for my Joe and I care
who you are yes you do one of the things
I do for my website is study to
statistics relative statistics of
personal income on the one hand versus
for the freedom index on the other hand
and if you study those things you
quickly realize a very huge correlation
between freedom indexes on the one hand
the freedom to start a business the
freedom to own property and the wealth
and success of the country so you look
at the most free countries you get your
United States is near the top Singapore
Australia New Zealand at the bottom you
get your Venezuela your Haiti your North
Korea and in the middle you get places
like China oh their per capita income is
lower than Mexico lower than Brazil
lower than South Korea lower than Taiwan
and I I guess my question is if we're
looking to eliminate poverty and
increase wealth shouldn't we be looking
to follow the model of the places that
succeed rather than following the model
of the places that fail or have mediocre
performance
well that that kind of ignores the role
of of history you know
it'd be nice to wipe out colonialism
wipe out his you know but the fact is
that China in 1949 or even in later you
know I had a per capita income of
$100.00 $150.00 and nothing you could do
you know you give them complete freedom
and that's not going to change you know
if you gave them the u.s. Freedom Index
they're not going to go from a hundred
dollars to fifty thousand dollars
overnight you ask what about the growth
rate that's what's in terms of what with
economic analyst what is the growth rate
and here the economic evidence is mixed
you know there are lots of people do
regressions but if you asked you know
[Music]
you know and there's lots of problems of
doing these correlations I'm gonna say
but but for instincts if you treat China
China's provinces as separate countries
as an example and each of those
provinces have 50 million or hundred
million so they're big countries you get
a very different result than if you
treat China as one data point and and so
you really have to be careful when you
do those correlations the fact is that
China has been the most successful in
terms of growth involving large numbers
of people over a 40-year period coming
for you Joe
no I think you're right I think the
level of freedom is a good predictor the
level of prosperity and that's really
supportive of the idea that market
freedoms
or very conducive to prosperity and then
I think the other thing that Joe is you
know then you want to start matching
changes and changes the change in in
prosperity it's called the growth rate
as you're talking about
and in China itself is a good example
when you when you did finally give
Chinese people a lot more market
freedoms then there was indeed the
greatest economic boom in world history
so that's that seems supportive of the
idea that more freedom goes with more
prosperity and changes as well as in
levels as what you were talking about oh
I get just saying that that it is true
that moving from the extremes that they
had of market control you know was
important but the government in the
period from 1978 on especially in the
first twenty five years after those
reforms the government still had a very
large control but let me make it very
clear you know particularly for advanced
countries there's absolutely no doubt
that more freedom better you know in an
appropriate way with a well regulated
system government for providing basic
institutional infrastructure
infrastructure din freh structure
investments in technology are going to
do well and going to do better but
that's not what we're talking about
right now we're really talking about in
these earlier stages development did
stronger countries with strong
government policies where the government
played an important role did they do a
particularly strong role in reducing
poverty but with respect to China I
think you earlier said in some other
question that you actually do believe
that China doesn't have the mix right
and that it actually does need more
market reforms than it has now
so you wanted to move in the direction
of more market reforms yeah okay and
final comment okay question yeah
professor Stiglitz professor easterly
great discussion I like the fact that it
was a discussion it takes away the air
of antagonism even though you guys have
had your moments we do debates here but
please ask your question is okay Jeanne
you always try to rush me and I just I
well I make nice with the guys but do it
afterwards of course alright I
understand I love you Jean I love Soho
for I love you to the Nick okay but
first a little bit about myself okay I
you guys have spoken generally about
some sort of mixture between
intervention case market society but if
you guys could be a little specific each
of you what is the aspect or aspects of
the others point of view that you find
most indispensable most beneficial
because I I you know I think it's about
common ground and maybe if you guys
found common ground that's a place that
we could start say something nice about
Bill Joe you go first Joe i I think I've
been saying nice things even nice I I
think as I said markets play an
important role in any successful society
I think the points that bill has made
that that marks the decentralization of
markets the opportunity for lots of
people to be involved you know the is an
important component to success the scope
it gives for individual entrepreneurship
is both important for individuals
themselves flourishing and and and for
society it's only that I also think you
all you can't you you need a framework
when with say that occur
just to mention one other you have to
have contract enforcement and you have
to have rules of the game and how you
set those rules the game markets don't
exist in a vacuum you have to have those
rules set somehow and so even the idea
that you could have markets without
government is is almost absurd you have
a jungle without government I mean the
economic freedom in us has the
enforcement of property rights in line
with what you said enforcement of
property rights which is important but
go ahead bill there's something nice you
already said it so I completely agree
with you Joe contract and everything
contract enforcement's honest courts
police there are obvious things that are
public goods that you do need government
of course and you've made that point
very eloquently with your usual grace
okay that's it they said something next
question yeah good evening I own and
operate a business in my native country
of Senegal in West Africa and I also
happen to believe that the only way you
can identify yourself no no don't do it
sorry your question is Professor hope
for whom to talk to to him they will
find out okay so I continue I also
happen to believe that the only route
out of poverty for my people in Senegal
is by allowing businesses to have the
kind access to the kind of same economic
freedom that we see in the Fraser
Institute economic freedom index
so my question is mr. Stieglitz do you
agree with that and if not could you
please tell me where would your bridge
with the economic freedom of businesses
I guess I don't know all the components
or again to the economic freedom index
so I can't really respond to that I mean
obviously
well so I just can't without knowing if
you want to ask me about any particular
freedoms that you want no it's I I guess
it's a bit troubling for me but when we
are standing here and talking about do
free market help countries get out of
poverty or not I do think that the
Fraser in to rephrase your Institute's
economic freedom is a very important one
I really I'm asking my question this way
because I thought I took for granted you
would know about it okay then bill you
want to take that question because maybe
you know more but you you once had your
name and a Fraser Institute publication
in 2006 economic freedom something maybe
you want to come in now you're finding
my old quotes okay so I don't know what
you want me to do I'm the academic
freedom index at its importance what you
view yeah no it's
I like the economic freedom index it's a
very heroic effort to put everything in
one index to measure the extent of
market freedom and I think it is
correlated in levels and changes with
prosperity and that's that's again
supportive evidence for the role of
markets and relieving poverty like my
god Wade was was talking about just now
thank you okay next question
yes I'd like to ask this question to all
the members on the stage why especially
professor Stiglitz why should I not
believe that economic power will
especially over the long run come to
dominate public power therefore leading
to oligopoly in the economy and and
anything but democracy so why should I
not believe that why should I not
believe that that I see it everywhere I
mean I I see everywhere
look as you said the government the
government's are under the control of
the economic power that's what I see
everywhere
yeah III think you're raising a very
difficult and very troubling issue that
that actually there are a number of
books are trying to grapple with that in
the absence of constraints the point
that there is a tendency for an
agglomeration of economic power and it's
been made worse I think with some of the
new technologies I think we've gotten
we've been very innovative in ways of
enhancing and extending market power so
market power has actually gotten much
worse there's a lots of evidence that
market power has gotten worse in the
United States and in many other
countries and the only curb on market
power is government and the that was
what we recognized in the antitrust laws
in the end of the last 19th century and
beginning of 20th and when they pass
those laws it wasn't about economics or
just economics they realized that this
concentration of market power would
inevitably undermine democracy and and
it has and there is a growing concern of
book that just recently came out gotten
a lot of attention and debate democracy
and chains for instance argued that
argued that the response oath of the
fear that that democracies would
naturally try to curb this kind of
market power and that the response of
the concentration those at the top of
the concentration of market power is
therefore to undermine democracy and to
curb democracy to put it into chains and
so
you get efforts at disenfranchisement
disempower a month and and constraining
Democratic space for democratic action
and undermining democracy I think that
was a real concerns and I think we're
seeing a play a lot of this being played
out today you know in our democracy well
there's something that puzzles me about
this line of argument I mean not just
you Joe but many commentators have these
positions that and I agree that there is
a real concern that government can be
captured by economic power and then the
monopolies will become much worse when
they are protected by government you
know when the government is going to
cooperate with economic monopolies to
limit entry into those industries or
they're given the benefit of trade
protection or whatever they want that's
when economic power is at its worst and
so you know there is a fear of the
government under democracy could be
captured by the economic power but then
how can you say at the same time that
the government is the answer to what you
lating these yo so more government
regulation is the answer if the
government has already been captured by
private interests I don't I don't get
the consistency so the consistency is
the following there are two points in
our original antitrust laws we in a
sense democratized our antitrust laws
and we said you could have private Suk's
because we were worried precisely about
capture so that's why we have civil
action as we have as well as as criminal
action we have state antitrust so we
have going from many many different
directions and an important in a global
economy
one of the checks say against the big
tech giants is that there are other
countries where they don't have the same
influence that they do in the United
States so that's one set of answers the
other one is that well there's a lot of
influence powering structure
episodically people get fed up and they
go to the polls and they demand a change
hopefully before it's too late and
that's what happened in the passage of
the antitrust laws at the end of the
19th century they said we're going in
this direction we can still get our
democracy back by curtailing the glom
raishin of a power of market power and
and they got it back so that there was
an awful lot of influence but they they
changed the direction for a long time we
have time for one final question just
please ask a question this won't just
sour has to be a final question yeah
those are Stiglitz if you look at
government the weaknesses often are
corruption the influence the fact that
the politicians and the bureaucrats work
what's in their interest which doesn't
always coincide with the interest of the
public and good policy for growth and
the election box is not always a perfect
remedy for that what under what
conditions do you see government really
functioning for the benefit of growth
and what are those times and how do you
deal with those problems when they do
not because of the problems I indicated
and other difficulties and for professor
easterly when you look at the private
markets one of the problems is of course
managers are different than the owners
of a business in modern day society in
many cases so you have a short termism
that sometimes creates problems which of
course also exists in government in
terms of Elections and then you also
have the difficulty of the fact that the
market is as a matter of survival of the
fittest and those there were at the
bottom sometimes a little trouble in
those markets where the government might
have a role in improving the conditions
as Professor Stiglitz has indicated what
do you see as those solutions to the
type of problems that exist with the
corporate sector and the private sector
which don't involve the government
creating more problems and in both case
particularly in the case of professor
Stiglitz how do you deal with the
problem that simple solutions to
problems often look the consequences
that will follow that not direct and can
cause more harm I think that I think
that's a perfect question for you
gentlemen to feel inspired in your final
summations and I'm glad you both took
notes so bill easterly you have your
five minutes of summation and Joe gets
to be cleanup hitter so bill you want to
take the podium for your five minutes of
summation thank you
so let's talk about some good news in
the last 25 years the global poverty
rate has fallen from 70% of the world's
population living in poverty to now 30
percent of the world's population living
in poverty and it's still going down and
Joe said correctly that there will be
some degree of poverty for a very long
time but the most extreme levels of
poverty are actually vanishing before
our eyes with the growth of the global
economy how is that happening it's going
on we are experiencing one of the
greatest booms of international trade
capital flows and migration and world
history the freedom to transact in
markets through there both migrating
trading investing worldwide people
matching freely with each other to
realize positive some gains of
interaction to markets is creating
remarkable opportunities we have
Egyptians exporting ceramic toilets to
Italy that's one of my favorite examples
of specializations who is the
development expert who had said the
answer is more toilets for Italy that
not I have not found one that's out
there Filipino is sending electronic
integrated circuits to the United States
Nigerians exported floating docks to
Norway entrepreneurs from Lesotho export
cotton trousers to American men while
fijian send cotton suits to American
women this remarkable specialization in
the world economy of international trade
has created opportunities worldwide for
poor people to get out of poverty and
it's the greatest success story of one
of the greatest success stories of our
era and that's I want to just revisit
again the idea that one reason markets
work so well is because of these three
channels that they get right that they
get right the incentive of both
consumers to find the best bargain and
find things that work for them that they
get to say what that what solves their
problems by operating in a bar
the gentleman just not mentioned
correctly that the consumers at the
bottom may not have enough money to meet
all of their needs the answer to that is
not dismantle markets and have
government takeover the answer to that
is some simple solutions that have
already been verified in some
development work and evidence that cash
transfers to the poor will alleviate
some of those problems to a napal poor
people to meet some of their basic needs
again the end is answer is simple give
them cash and let them then choose them
for themselves in markets what what
works for them so markets get those
incentives right markets get the no
knowledge right that the people at the
bottom both entrepreneurs and consumers
know best what solves their own problems
and lastly this point that's very
important to me we've talked a little
bit today about rights I just want to
stress again that markets in our own day
have shown themselves to be the has
historically the most unprecedented
system that has ever been known and in
our world today for allowing peoples
that are otherwise states that are
otherwise seemingly at each other's
throats in terms of state rivalry the
peoples like Iran and Russia and the US
and and all of these in Ted and Middle
Eastern nations but in the meantime the
peoples of these nations are engaged in
peaceful mutually beneficial
transactions through migration and trade
and investment and it's right it's it's
not perfect it's not flawless it's not
utopia but it's the best we've ever seen
in in world economic history that has
led indeed to that grating decrease in
poverty that I mentioned it and that's
something we should really celebrate
that markets have achieved thank you
very much
[Applause]
by pointing out that that the this
dichotomy between markets and government
is a little bit phony that that in fact
every successful society has to have
both markets and government and it's
really getting the right balance between
the two and I would add more than just
markets and government it's about civil
society and the reason I see all these
is together is that the systems of
checks and balances that in the absence
of one you can get the problems that
have been identified in the other so
it's when you say we've been successful
over the you know last numerous years of
moving people out of poverty or it's
because we have a variety of mixed
systems and the particular mixture at
that particular moment in China where
there was a lot of government is they
focused not just on growth but making
sure that that benefit of growth was
reflected in a movement of poverty there
are other places where there's been
growth but that growth didn't do as much
of a job of moving people out of poverty
the last question I thought was very
much to the point where it pointed out
what economists called is the basic
principal agent problem the basic
problem that the managers of firms don't
really maximize the well-being of large
enterprises the long-run well-being of
the corporations or let alone of society
as a whole and the elected officials
don't always maximize the well-being of
our
country they have their own agenda there
are it we call incentive misalignments
that are pervasive in our society and
they are they would be less severe if we
have perfect information but we don't
have perfect information and so in the
presence of these imperfections of
information they are going to be part of
our society and therefore we have to try
to learn how to make each of our parts
of our system work and work better and
when they do we can get a more efficient
system but I also we can get a system
going back to the question that delivers
more out of poverty
and in societies where there hasn't been
that kind of growth like right now in
India they're very successful in
creating billionaires but much less
successful in moving people out of
poverty and so unless you have a a kind
of balance where you can make sure that
there is growth and the some of the
fruits of that growth go to the people
at the bottom you won't have an
effective way of addressing inequality
and in the long run you won't even have
a strong economic growth
[Applause]